[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt's ein vegetarisches
hauptgericht und zwar werde ich einen
auberginen zucchini kraft zu bereiten
und diese krappa ist geschichte mit
etwas tomatensoße uns wirklich sehr
einfach ist es vegetarisch und auch ganz
einfach vorzubereiten
deswegen startet gleich mit den zutaten
und zeigt für euch mal dafür brauche ich
drei esslöffel olivenöl bei auberginen
zucchini eine dose tomaten stücke hier
habe ich jeweils einen teelöffel minze
und oregano nämlich zwei großaufträge
salz pfeffer und etwas und beim käse
nämlich nur überbacken immer gerne
kaffee
das ist so ein türkischer tee so ähnlich
ihr könnt aber auch zum beispiel gouda
oder auch im schlaf geben egal was ihr
möchtet ich nehme mir zuerst einmal die
auberginen und wertet hobeln mache hier
mit einer küchenmöbel ihr könnt sie aber
auch zum beispiel mit einem messer in
gleichmäßige scheiben schneiden
erst rutschte monate vorweg
[Musik]
die aubergine werde damit ein bisschen
wasser ziehen und beim anbraten nicht so
viel fett aufsaugen und auch die
bitterstoffe ein bisschen entscheidung
richtig liegt hier mit etwas zahlen und
west und später ein bissle ausdrücken
[Musik]
kurz zur seite und jetzt auch dies trieb
ihn in feine scheiben auf
[Musik]
jetzt kennen viele tomaten dosis zu
bereiten und dafür habe ich jetzt die
knoblauchzehen fein
[Musik]
youtube
jetzt noch die kräuter reim und mit salz
und pfeffer und noch viel zucker
abschmecken
crystal habe ich jetzt allerdings
herausgestellt
[Musik]
gehe ich ein bisschen olivenöl in einer
pfanne und ich mir mit seiner
beschichtete pfanne
da ich jetzt bei dem gemüse einfach
nicht so viel hilfe benötige die fahne
ist auch mittel hohe hitze und werde
jetzt die zucchini scheiben und auch die
auberginen scheiden nach dem aufwachen
und auf brücken für etwa eine minute auf
jeder seite anbraten
[Musik]
blut
jetzt sichtlich dass auberginen zucchini
papa und ich nehme dafür kleine
gusseisernes pfännchen unfall beginnt
habt könnt ihr auch eine große
auflaufform zum beispiel nehmen sie
solltet ihr allerdings vorher hätten bei
dem hufeisenförmigen fotoaufnahmen sie
nicht retten muss wenn sie vorher einmal
eingebrannt werden
jetzt kommt da eine stiftung
verschiedenen gremien und dann gekommen
[Musik]
habe ich von allem die hälfte braucht
nur zwischen rein so auch fest schön
wenn man diese innere haltung des bundes
wache und dann kommt das ganze noch mal
auftraten
[Musik]
youtube
ein
[Musik]
und das klappt kommt ist in vorbereitung
ober unterhitze
[Musik]
jetzt ist es fertig und ferien selbst
mehr auf dem holzpferd vorträgt ganz
heim turnier findet auch da dann die
rathenower vom kindergarten abgeholt
abgeholt und ist jetzt richtig
vegetarisch und richtig heißt ja ich
habe etwas nachgelassen aber ich habe es
die anderen wieder in den ofen
denn wir wollen uns gerne wahr da war
gerade mit zuschauerfragen dann einige
park auf der theke mit kruden ich schaff
das nicht meine freundin zum beispiel
die verträgt den appell ist eigentlich
keine laktose aber die vertreten weil da
irgendwie elektro vidal einfach so
gering ist dass wir da nicht drauf
reagiert okay dann muss man nämlich
anscheinend gucken wie viel zucker dass
die flughafen-kontrollen schmeckt sehr
gut aber fleisch und ich finde es kann
man so entweder mal als zwischen mars
und weil ich habe keine nudeln oder
keine kartoffel mit dabei oder man nimmt
halt als beilage ich glaube seine
zuschauer müssen dass ich ein fleisch
werden wenn aber eine super varian eine
vegetarische variante entlassen und das
kannst du auch größere natürlich mit
fängt genau das habe ich halt voll aus
zum anrichten wenn man jetzt gehabt
ansonsten großen auflaufen
ich etwas schmeckt gut sind so firm mit
karla so richtig lecker und fritz und
falls ihre präsenz nach machen wollt
gibt das auf handys - glocke jeder steht
noch mal ich werde einfach nur ziemlich
für die samira zubereiten und peter
aubergine und verklingen müsste dann
auch verwehren man auch mit seinen
kindern
naja wir werden trotzdem schaffen und
ich wünsche euch viel spaß beim
nachmachen und hier erlebten damit du
nicht mehr essen muss oder kann der
kamera richtig schön dass ich mich echt
lecker also lud mich wie man die
vegetarier auf jeden fall genial für
mich auch als
[Musik]